this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
uh Brennan you're we're at the drinking
Bros podcast uh Studios we've moved to
Austin we want to thank them drinking
Bros
um Dan Holloway is that how you say your
last name Dan
Holloway
my boy
um uh and uh Ross Patterson
who we did so Ross we did range 15 with
that's right yeah and I dude I was on
the drinking Bros uh hot second ago yeah
now is that was that 1997 that's right
it was that 94. Brennan is very very
distracted because he keeps looking
behind us going they have more depth
than we do on the set recess until the
fighter and kids Studios have correct
more depth correct well it's a great
setup Man compared to ours with it you
know how about the fact that yesterday
in Austin there's a bachelorette party
and you know we're used to being only or
well all our fans are Bros and this very
attractive girl in her 20s is like oh my
God can I please take a picture with you
guys and I was like Yay and the rest of
the bachelorette party looked at us like
who the [__] are these regular dudes
yeah but they were warlocks but they
were the warlocks they were the warlocks
like who are they remember and just the
hot one recognized that is actually true
that's right I don't want to call them
warlocks but they were they some of
those those gals are like I'm in Austin
and I'm gonna drink and eat all the food
yeah and we're gonna have some fun but
I'm gonna wear yeah yeah those gals were
lizzo fans and the the cool one was our
fans right that might be a very
politically correct correct way of
saying that somebody hasn't been missing
a lot of meals yeah dude we're moving to
Austin yeah let's not get carried away
no I've this I got good news and bad
news I've already bought a place I
didn't know that yeah are you looking at
yeah I think that uh the idea is to live
out on the outskirts of Austin yeah Fort
Worth
that's really outskirts yeah I'll do
that's what I'm talking about I don't
see anybody I'm just gonna zoom into the
POD live on my land yeah you know porch
yeah everybody everybody has this
fantasy of having your own animals and
access to a well and your gyms are
CrossFit your your garage is a CrossFit
Studio what yeah
I don't do have that picture I'd be good
dude yeah that'd be good
yeah what do you think it was hot out
here though hotter than the sun you know
what because you're in Manhattan though
I'm in I'm in the Valley it gets about
105 110 where I'm at bud this is no
different for me yeah this is a little a
little more um moist a little thicker
yeah did you watch the fights last night
I watched the fights last night I I
thought with the Nate first of all
didn't know the UFC was even going on
but I watched the Corey sandhagen fight
of course against Rob five not you know
not though yeah well just you know he
got the job done but it's not in the
core is my boy but it's not gonna it's
not gonna win any favors with Uncle Dana
get to a title shot sometimes fights
happen that way though
you got to go for at that level you kind
of now it's the safe route and you're
you're gonna get a big fight next he's
ranked whatever three yeah but you're
not gonna like if you would have
starched them yeah you're talking
everyone's like oh I can't wait to see
court now no one's saying that so so so
the better his coach you have a game
plan but but you're saying stand and
bang no I'm not saying stand in bang I'm
uh a fighter on two week notice Rob
font's not known for his takedown
defense first two rounds let's drainage
energy keep him active third round keep
on the feet fake faint the shots and
light them up yeah get let's get a
finish yeah
and so yeah you know and that's what and
that's also what the UFC brass is
expecting we're not expecting a five or
one decision highlight reels oh in in
San Diego he's not known for his
wrestling in tenacity like that like
they put him on there like Kate we found
your opponent yeah let's get it done and
when you do that they go okay you think
that's that's kind of conveyed to Corey
because Dana he apologized on Instagram
today he goes hey uh something like
sorry I know what you guys want to
expect be cool though it's a different
lesson in master class because we
haven't seen him use his wrestling like
that so those guys know they know but
they're also like [__] it all right who
else are you gonna throw got the W and
Corey and Corey's anything is different
where he's like whoever you want to
bring on I'm going to beat him before I
become Champion so if if your way of
disciplining me is fighting marab that's
what I want yeah so he's different yeah
but other guys you know like a sugar
Shawn or
um you know Izzy they know like I'm
gonna start just dude so I can get a
paid be a huge fight yeah
yeah but the more exciting fight was uh
Nate Diaz and uh Jake Paul yeah man
first of all Nate Diaz as rugged as they
come and we know that though yeah yeah
and but but but
um I and I I kind of figured it would go
something like that no you didn't no I
did because Nate is so rubbery Nate's
just he's so hard to get out of there
he's he can roll he sits there he kind
of covers up he's bigger than people
think he's he's also kind of big he's
beefy Nate when I hung out with him in
San Diego weighed 191 pounds that's a
substantial guy I mean one of the things
that people have noticed for me anyway
because I'm 170 and a small friend
everyone's I was like he's his head is
way bigger than I thought his arms are
super long he's he's got a big frame now
his brother Nick is even bigger yeah but
but 190 is substantial when you're
walking around and and I think um so I
wasn't surprised at that size thing and
I wasn't surprised he was able to
weather those people it's not even that
it's it's just you know he has a lot of
miles on on a lot of miles you didn't
know how serious she's gonna take the
fight so when people even my brothers
hit me up because hey my Joey and I
Anthony wanted you on the inside to Nate
because he's a plus 375 dog I go Nate's
Not a Bad Bet It's Not a Bad Bet to
assume he's gonna be some version that
we're used to in the UFC and Jake can't
get him out of there so it's not a bad
bet that but again to win yes so so I
said it's all predicated on his first
three rounds that and that that uh
predictions based off of Nate being more
weathered than he was yeah they look
pretty good his Carter is pretty good
great but Jake definitely won the fight
now I think so here's what I'm saying in
round nine Jake had to grab on to Nate
because he got rocked and that was
impressive as [__] I was like dude dude
this can this can happen like he got
tagged up in round nine was he around
five I I understand I understand but
round nine yeah it almost flew through
the ropes but round nine he he answered
back and and hit him a ton of times when
and Jake had to grab him what I'm
impressed with is Jake Paul I'm
impressed by both no I'm impressed but I
just think Jake Jake is being taken
seriously by everybody you would think
if you don't take him seriously then you
got a problem he hasn't been he's been
boxing for a very short period of time
relatively this is and he's in there and
he looks good that's the main as the
main drawer
I thought that was the best performance
he's had and Nate's no you know slouch
it was a good fight I thought uh yeah I
thought Jake passed the test what's next
for him I think you know they talk about
this MMA fight I don't I think that'd be
a bad idea for Jake to do right now yeah
you know and also Jake has to deal with
pfl
this is what people are forgetting
Nate's never going to sign with another
organization I just don't think it's
going to happen especially pfl
competitor UFC because he wants that
Conor McGregor Trilogy fight that's
still there that's money if he signs
with pfl Dan's like forget about this
then like his fight for for Nate I think
it's about beating Conor again not Jake
and MMA that does nothing for Nate yeah
he should beat him yeah and when so are
you going to fight on the UFC or are you
going to fight on Jorge's because you
because you're you're training now right
I'm Jake Paul's next fight what yeah no
I would die I know I can't I can't can't
what I can't why why do you keep egging
this fight on I'm I'm talking here out
loud you like Don King dude I'm just
saying it looks like you're watching
your we went to get donuts today and you
were like can't and I went what you
can't have a cake donut that's maple
glazed you go no and I was like why is
it not trimming the tummy I'm doing some
road work you you came to my room this
morning all sweaty like you'd had a
workout in and I was like you look
showered what times you wake up and you
were like ah nah I I just got up moving
around a little bit you're keeping
things from me what's up fam hopefully
you guys are enjoying this episode of
the fighting the kid we are in Austin
Texas so we're using the drinking Bros
podcast Studio hope you guys are
enjoying it we'll be back to regular
business next week Cal is in Dallas all
week with Crowder her Alex Jones doing
the damn thing so hope you guys are
enjoying the episodes live from Austin
but don't get it twisted just because we
did in Austin we still came with the
macadamias baby the house of macadamias
you know how they do Daddy they got the
chocolate dipped the raspberry white
chocolate flavored is my uh Vibe
callan's always doing the vanilla or the
chocolate dip they are the best
macadamia nuts on planet Earth it's not
just for the rich it's not just for Elon
and Jeff Bezos anymore it used to be but
thanks to House of macadamus they're
using local farmers over nine the
farmers that they use for these
macadamia nuts they recently dropped the
new house of macadamia milk right here
this 100 macadamia nut milk right here
delicious House of macadamias macadamia
that goes right into your coffee all you
do is put this little this little packet
right here you put this in uh
some water eight ounces of water put
that in your coffee tell me you're gonna
find better tasting coffee than this
half Summits 100 Macadamia goes directly
in your dark dark roast coffee it's the
best in the biz and you get House of Mac
Davis you want to try it cool let me
hook you up they're gonna give you guys
and they never do discounts we go to
houseomeacademias.com tfak you get 20
off this Macadamia 100 Macadamia in your
coffee the chocolate dip nuts you get
the bars all right you get 20 off all
that but also the giving away a box of
the variety pack Macadamia bars you get
the 45 Mac name the snack bars one of
each flavor that you can pick then he
saved 20 off they're giving you that
full free when you go to House of
macadamias.com tfak that's 20 off your
entire order with code tfak macadamias
House of macadamias you're welcome
you're keeping things from me moving
around keeping your shoulders can't be
trusted dude you're informant but I just
I'm I'm saying that your plant I'm not a
government plan I'm saying I saw some
numbers thrown around I'm talking I'm
talking if if we can get you in the ring
get it we all need some cash here no I
will say this the amount of money
Jorge's team threw around is let's take
it easy it's it it pumps your ego up and
I appreciate you have that value
retention you got all my attention and
it's it's it's a real stroke to the ego
I appreciate that I really do okay let
me see I'm not worth that I'll tell you
right now no you're gonna lose all your
money right well well I'll say this
people that they would throw in front of
you
not just Brian Callan but there are
people that they would throw in front of
you by the way it was just a boxing
match I'm going to Pepper your face up a
little bit right sure but if it's not me
there are other people that you'd have a
hard time not at least entertaining
correct and that's where we're at right
now and it's not it's not Derek I'm not
fighting Derek Lewis
MMA fight that allows head Stomps that's
not happening head stops that that's the
offer I got and Brian's like entertain
it dude you could do you just take him
down I'm like are you out of your phone
no no when I heard there were head stops
I was like well I can't have that I
can't have that so that's not happening
but now eating I can't have you doing a
podcast eating out of a straw no it's
not happening you know where I gotta
wipe the drool off your mouth that's not
good it's not happening it's not
happening now but now some other names
though I went same money we could figure
out
I could beat that guy tonight
okay now big names too big names I won't
call anybody out because you know I
don't wanna no you big boy you big boy I
like Nick when he met you nick uh Nick
Simmons who is my boy great guy yeah and
my my you know my opener and and New
York Comics Nick goes uh Nick hung out
with Brendan and Nick's a New York Comic
and and when Brennan was on stage Nick
turns me and goes he's the nicest
[__] guy he's the nicest guy I go
he's my best friend what the [__] do you
think I'm hanging out with him for I'm
not banging him yeah you know and stay
off the internet what are you talking
about yeah and then um and then but Nick
also was like he's because Nick is
strong and Nick works out and sure he
goes he's so much bigger than I thought
yeah I go yeah he's he's a giant you're
talking about bam bam now yeah I know
you lift a lot of weights I know you do
a lot of stuff but you it's a little
different level now talking about a
different level he Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam he goes yeah yeah he goes I he goes
something like he said something like
and what you know I was thinking about
it too it was like everybody walks
around like a tough guy we were in this
room with a lot of people and he goes
but if he locked that door he he could
take me you and everybody else in that
room huh I go that's correct so you're
dealing with Bam Bam most rooms deal
with Bambam dealing with a big old
gorilla everybody else monkey now so
having said all that me Nick are friends
now having said all that I'm gonna I'm
gonna let me look Derek Lewis no no no
to him an absolutely not I'm not even
entertaining absolutely no but they're
no absolute no's there's some numbers
that you're throwing around what I'm
trying to say is this
ah
if I write you a check right now if I
push a check if I run it I'm going to
write a number on a piece of paper
now take it easy now calm down we're
talking sure this is five million
dollars okay headstops
you gotta fight the Beast Derek I'm just
talking no no no no no five million
wouldn't do it okay now here's the thing
here's the thing you're not far off
that's what's insane easy that's what's
insane take it easy
that's insane let's not start throwing
numbers around just everybody calm down
I'm just saying we're on the internet
hey hey people are going to run with
these things all right take it easy
listen Hey listen I'm not trying to make
you feel shitty I'm not that's not my
intention yeah but let's say they're at
offer you a fight right yeah yeah what
do you think you're worth hey bro don't
be a dick no dude no dude I'm just dude
it's not about me and you versus Mark
we're the same we're the same Burger
somebody tough guy like hey what do you
think you're worth hey bro come on I I
think if I was in all honest actor in
all honesty you're getting two and two
foreign
it sucks right [__] off I'm fine let's
not throw that out hey you're not
getting you're not getting no that's
insane can you imagine someone pay that
for my dumbass
but there are one million I'm fine hey
can you call me five million bread now
I'm not calling you that spending five
million you don't take any of my offers
seriously you don't take any of my
offers seriously hey all [__] aside
how serious were they oh no it was
pretty wild
it's pretty wild and then my man's
relaxed my brother from another mother
Lex calls me literally the next one goes
talk to Dean man where's your hat out on
this thing I'm like what what the [__]
what are you talking about first he said
I know you called him no at first he
brought you into the room and he goes
because I was all because here's the
thing about it
I'm obviously getting my piece not to be
a dick but I have you gotta wet your
beak well because otherwise my mouth
starts to run I don't want my mouth to
run we can't have that so you wanna you
wanna keep my beak wet keep me happy
yeah
big dry stupid thing my beak has been in
the sand for quite a while so you're not
I'm not I'm not letting you go fight and
get all the attention without cutting
your manager and it's also good for
Ratings you want that need a piece yeah
need a piece that's good manners yeah
that's a good business that's called
good business it means you're a good
business respectful to your own to your
to your [__] Elders to your mentors
you know what and I like where your
head's at on this because for 12 years
now my back's killing me from Kansas
City hey dude so I was like oh Brian's
taking some initiative I don't know this
is great yeah now now Lex because I
started to get I got super excited you
in the room an old talking he took him
into the room and went hey we're not
doing this what the what are you
thinking because I could see you a
little competitive well you got a little
competitive did he say don't do it well
then then he then then they started
throwing around some things then you
start hearing something everybody's got
a number everybody's got a number
everybody's got a number oh yeah no I'll
do only fans for a certain number that's
right I'll show my feet my weiner I
don't care there you go for a certain
number that number not only fans would
you do I'm gonna give you I'm writing
you a check you got to do a little guy
guy stuff yeah a little College stuff
well we're moving around that's all you
just move around I'm gonna find you a
good looking young a young twink and you
can move around just like oil up and
wrestle there's no penetration look you
for all the joke inside that you make
fun of me being a basically a half a gay
man yeah
with the right with poppers and and just
some feel-good drugs I promise you you
go 100 are you a good check I'm gonna
get you I'm giving you a good check and
I'm Gonna Get You Sauced up on all the
right nitrates oh I've found all the
right I mean damn what's the drug what's
the what's the drug What's the sex drug
we got molly huh DNA so we get little
Molly in them get a couple Toots and
blow but with Viagra mixed in there so
he doesn't lose his dong dude if I
didn't have kids line the boys up
[__] video for the right amount
the problem is the kids the kids are the
damper Bubba oh dude the kids came over
Dad they get bullied for them College
your friends are like what'd you what'd
you say and they just show that game
over like I'm done
yeah all right well that's good so so so
uh yeah I I'm very into this Converse
conversation you're more into it than I
well there are no there are people out
there there are reasonable opponents out
there
uh and there are and if the number's big
enough
I'm gonna have to push you into it and
how weird is it that this came about and
then also because I've been pushing
Bradley Martin I'm basically bro I'm the
Brian count of the Bradley Martin
situation push him into it he wants to
do it and then you know I can move a
Shaker yeah I want to be there I think
we do it it got it got taken another
level because now uh Jake Paul and his
podcast offered Bradley Martin a fight
against Mike Perry and Mike Perry came
out was like Bradley I'm 180 pounds I'll
fight 180 whatever whatever you want to
do come in this heavy as you want we
love Bradley and Bradley is not a
fighter Bradley is is a smart guy with a
great business and doesn't need to do
that and because we love Brad keep that
energy with me you [__] no no hold on
because we love Bradley he's our boy
we're not letting Bradley fight a
veteran monster like Mike Perry now
Bradley's too smart to do that now hold
on now hold on no I I sent Bradley I go
did you see Mike this is real dude
that's real money there and he goes hey
he goes I'm not trying to be shitty man
I'm not trying to climb anybody I've
never heard of Mike Perry I don't know
who that is yeah in our world he's a big
deal in bare knuckle he goes he's a big
deal in UFC I went he was a character
but to have a ton of success in UFC but
bare knuckle he's the face of it he's
the most successful crossover but he was
also a legit UFC you know fighter I mean
not Contender but not a contender but a
legit and beer knuckle he's the best
now hold on Mike Perry 180 pounds and
they what about grappling what about
just no absolutely nothing just not just
grappling no no you give a better shot
against Mighty Mouse than Mike Perry and
grappling Mike Perry is still a still
went through the system of grappling no
no MMA but but you're talking Mighty
Mouse one of the greatest black belt I'm
saying just grappling if they just do
grappling you don't think you don't
think Bradley has a better shot against
Mike Perry grappling the Mighty Mouse
absolutely oh wow that's weird he's too
big too big strong my pair is bigger
than 180. my perry walks around at one
at 200 pounds at least Mike's a thick
kid
them on a few months ago he's not that
thick Well everybody's short too
everybody's smaller to you but I'm
telling you if you weighed if Jorge
mosman always 205 right now my perry
weighs 200 but you would rather have
Bradley grapple Mighty Mouse because
he's lighter but way more Tech not even
close no no
idea because Bradley is so big and
Mighty Mouse is much smaller so you
think he has a better shot against I I
don't think you'd have a better shot
against Mike and grappling in both
situations because Bradley doesn't train
and grapple well of course both the odds
are against him but you wouldn't rather
have him go against a guy who's not a
traditional Grappler he's not a black
belt both situations are not are are not
going to be surprising when Bradley gets
his back taken or something he's just
it's just see I think Brad if it's just
grappling I think Bradley has a much
better I don't think he beats either
what has a better chance for longer of
having success against Mike Perry as far
as just Jiu Jitsu wrestling does meaning
how do you define success lasting longer
lasting longer not getting submitted my
mouse is too quick too technical I don't
know
I'm just saying when it comes to that
you know his technique's not at a
world-class level as far as grappling
goes against a bigger guy like Brad
that's not fair to Bradley for this he
Bradley's not saying he's a fighter I
love that Bradley's trolling and saying
hey I think I I you know let's see
because he's so well that was his eye
but that I didn't bring it I would never
put somebody that's this is all he's
doing yeah and I was like all right I
make it happen but we're gonna make it
happen
now we're not going to have you fight
anybody until we have got you trained
and ready you're 40 yeah you move you
don't have any injuries I mean you just
don't have any injuries so you can train
so how's your foggy brain how's your not
really you just don't though you don't
have a foggy brain either you just don't
maybe it's the 15 nicotine patches in
your face all the time yeah that helps
my friend found out my friend was doing
nicotine and he saw how many you did
yeah he was like wait how many that's
nuts you're from [__] porn [__] if
you're gonna do it do it man just go
hard heavy yeah I don't do anything
moderation
yeah you were telling me you you uh we
were having a conversation and Brendan's
I've said uh you you what do you do to
work out a deadlift I deadlift I uh what
else do you do pull-ups deadlift and
dumbbell bit and dumbbell benches that's
it and I said I said what yeah are you
using a crossbar no no because I'm not a
vagina okay I use a straight bar I was
like oh I'm sorry look at you you the
same thing huh just a straight bar a
couple thickies back there too
this were like old [__] like it's
like it's like people that are like cold
cold plunge man check out this new
technology yeah oh check this out dude
creatine you've heard of creatine you
guys been doing that since excuse me
I've been doing that since you were in
four my call to even have one of those
like my weight room doesn't even have
one of those gay thing what is it the
[__] I mean yeah no it's not real but no
it's just pick up boxes no no no no
because I do it I do it don't no because
it's good for new trainers like it's
safer for your back then don't do it
then don't do it no no but then if you
can't do it no no I'm doing it if you're
not doing the real thing don't do it no
no please let me just do some deadlift
for my hex bar yeah why not no man you
you so you'd put me over in the uh in
the section the oldest I wasn't even
entertain him like just don't don't sign
up at this gym
it's not for you you know
I'm over there just doing it yes what
about the one the belt what about the
belt squat you put a belt on it's
hanging between your legs and you're
just going down there you go that's a
hack squat yeah but you better get a
kettlebell and just do drops yeah no
there's all sorts of stuff you can do
man yeah
it's just making people softer I'm happy
with the way this this red shirt looks
on me and I'm looking a little thick the
shirt says fight like hell yeah George
Washington you've wore some interesting
shirts lately yeah
when I was doing a stand-up with you
um he had a shirt on and had a skull you
had a skull on your shirt yeah it's my
boy Kevin Max uh uh shirt hold on no
hold up hold on let me call real quick
oh it's Affliction they're out of
business yeah no no but that was that
takeoff on the Misfits I think or there
was some rock group I like that skull
you don't wear skulls no no no hey you
too old dude deadlifts not for you no
what no skull shirts I want to do
deadlifts deadlift not for you what do
you mean all right deadlift's not for
you no listen just overall mainly [__]
enough for you right but that's [__]
I do [__] I hey I do and skull
t-shirts right not free do you remember
how about this not for anybody how about
this I was doing it and these guys are
all not in their head because we know
because we're not tools okay listen
tools listen I'm doing deadlift and the
only time I've been I'm rarely
embarrassed very hard to embarrass me
and I was I was doing straight bar
deadlifts with one 35
and I one of the things I noticed was my
left arm is impossibly skinny and I'm
doing deadlifts just curve at the Frog
arms and who walks in but Brendan and
Tim Tebow
and they were there to work out
and and they and they see me dead
lifting and and Tim goes uh-oh oh look
at this guy look at this guy and I I put
the weight down and I stepped away and I
I think we got into a pull-up contest
because that's the only thing I could do
I was like ah you guys go ahead and lift
I want to be over here yeah I'm gonna
kick the bag I'm gonna Pitter Pat the
bag and do some grab the water
Tim is such a beautiful looking human
being strong and
strong boy can deadlift he can deadly
he's got legs see you don't have much
around you have a boxy butt yeah I got
quads I got a bit of a piece I kind of
have quads your lower body isn't what
I'm not as happy with it not one I can
bring Tim Tebow yeah but I got some you
know you don't have the belly of the
muscle isn't really no when I came in
it's like it's like weather it's rain
because I dropping no I don't tear drops
it's not true you don't want to rain I
want you to have tear drops everywhere
because I ride my bike so much no no
you're compared to Tim Tebow no it's not
that if you if you wanted to get into
bodybuilding that unfortunately all the
guys who looked at you they would do
this they'd say you got to come over
here and they bring you in a room they
go you don't have the genetics in the
legs or the ass and you'd be like what
like I'm built like a stingray yeah you
just yeah you too yeah he's strong yeah
but just don't have the you don't have
the you know the belly or the belly of
the muscle you get the cat yeah I like
that myself those big quads with the
teardrops yeah I know what you're
talking about she did not have that I
wish you don't have that no Bobby you
don't I do you got the Samoan you got
that Samoan like the big big box oh dude
you're saying you're saying epoxy I got
Samoan top white girl bottom Maybe a
little bit right yeah you know that it's
all right well no my name is a little of
my energy when I see you really a little
bit because I'll see like there's a
picture of you in GSP on the you know
that his cats are bigger yeah he's got
those he's got those great teardrop
things you're you know you're you're
there yeah but the air you must smoke in
Sprint right right
did you sprint against GSP smoke them
right
you faster than G I don't know why you
put them in this situation I'm asking
questions you question myself did you
guys do a little comments so you're
saying I got I got a Polynesian upper
body yeah a white girl lower body black
man dick I never said that either yep
but you're listen your dick is
participating it's in the game it's it's
there it is it's not gonna blow your
hair back I gotta blow your hair back
but there is but you're gonna go we can
work with that you work with it you know
we can work oh no oh no I got my work
cut out you got shoulders you got girls
are not that into a I mean some of them
are but a lot of girls are going to be
they're not going to be in they're not
gonna be you know yeah they're not into
huge excuse me yeah this sounds like
you're a small leg right huh it sounds
like you're a small dick that's small
big energy no we know I don't though
yeah I know I've seen that thing yeah
you got a day kind of dude I do that
Daddy that's it that's one thing I can't
think away dude your genetics suck but
your dick hey what am I doing next I got
an apple bottom not bad you average guy
right not really though because I got I
got energy
average guy with big dick energy don't
say average guy because
um I'm I'll surprise you no you're built
to hit the field like it like you know
like [__] just two just a little no
you know what you're weak you know what
you're built for it you know what you're
built for raking
[Laughter]
at least [__] Daddy's got guys yeah
he's got a surprising amount of
flexibility daddy would have been great
dancer a little sausage hey it's all
right moving around right hey but it's
all right it's not like exceptional no
you know it was crazy flexible Joe Joe
Rogan is the most flexible [__]
on the planet it's like his own dick I
bet 100 yeah he is at 56 he is he can do
the splits I don't know anybody at that
age you can do that he's [__] weird
we we had a meeting one time in
Hollywood and this was when he we were
probably 32.
and he he was like you do martial arts
huh he goes yeah I want to work my
flexibility he goes what do you mean and
he grabbed both he was sitting on the
couch he grabbed both his [__] yes he
grabbed both his ankles and pulled them
out the way a porn star you know when a
porn star just opens her legs like a
stripper in a Hollywood meeting he just
went in jeans and I was like what the
[__] and the guy was like oh my God and
he wears those flexible jeans oh yeah
those pills Bill Russell sidekick jeans
I remember the first time he got through
these jeans I think Chuck Norris owned
that brand really yeah Chuck Norris
because he was gonna like throw a high
kick at any given time well I remember
when Joe said I finally found jeans that
fit my butt on my legs because he's
quatted out he's got those those and
yeah he doesn't ask yeah and he's a gay
man Delight he is flexible like that
anymore now he's a Bridge Troll you get
older and you just you know you just
become I don't know there's a lot of gay
dudes to be all into that he's yeah he's
daddy he's Daddy to a lot of twinks
big sugar daddy you can pay all my bills
and oh yeah you know he's attractive I
mean there are a lot of I don't know
though I used to be I used to be yummy
to gay men and I knew I was getting
older when they just stopped looking at
me I was on the beach with my my my wife
our dear friends uh she the the our one
this woman has a lot of gay friends and
these gay men come down to the beach
with us they have they don't have kids
Papa and they're in their 30s so you
know what they do all day yeah they
can't pray they do Barry's boot camp and
lift weights so every one of them looks
like a CrossFit champion because that's
what they do and they're probably
working some trt and stuff because if
you're gay you're you're your tits and
ass are you better be on point yeah so
they're all shaved down jacked out of
their [__] minds and just busting
nuts in each other oh I mean they were
and every single one of them was
actually the volleyball spike ball I
mean all kids a lot of them were from
the south
so they grew up doing sports and
pretending they were straight then they
had to migrate to California feel safe
so a lot of them you meet them and
they're they're they're I swear to God
they're all dudes they're dudes right I
had no idea any of them were gay no idea
because hey relax a little relax hey
relax a little bit yeah they're doing
this yeah relax a little bit I'm telling
you yeah and they're all jacked out of
their minds and then I realized oh
you're from Alabama and I go it was fun
to be growing up gay in Alabama and
religious yeah and he goes he goes dude
you got no idea that's why there's no
there's no affectation there was no
effeminate stuff because the Southern
Boys grew up having they were playing
baseball football they suppressed them
they didn't suppress the sugar in the
tank now now they're all hanging out
with each other there was a point to
that I was making oh they didn't look at
you because they didn't because you look
like [__] I took my shirt off and I
looked at him I go guys I'm gonna take
my shirt off and I apologize for being
old and yummy
not I could have been a cup of coffee
because back in the day they used to cat
call you bro back in the day in my 20s
and my 30s that's sad right I was a
[__] cutie you're cute I was a cutie
pie when we start when two when we were
here doing a podcast with Tim uh Kennedy
the first time yeah that you and I had
ever met him that on it I looked at
those pictures no gray black hair nice
beard sharp nose sharp features cutie I
was a cute kid you've aged like a banana
I sure have I was a cutie pie you age
like a president [__] a man you get
old we both gotten older though God damn
those old school picks Eric Williams
showed us
[Music]
life will get you you get older man I
forget you brother I forget you kids
waking up early like we did today well I
cannot sleep in it I went to bed last
night we got done with the fight
companion almost one
I was in bed by three and I'm like I
gotta be up by seven to get ready for
this pod you know it doesn't matter I
just I don't even need to set an alarm
no because we're two hours ahead so it's
five a.m I'm up at 5am no matter what
you are every single day and you you
were you were old puff you came to my
you came to my room this morning and uh
who's not puffy in the morning he's not
puffy in the morning yeah when you eat
the burritos and stuff I didn't eat a
burrito last night I didn't sleep enough
you don't sleep enough I never sleep
enough yeah yeah you're all puffed up
now that you're puffy your puffiness is
coming down Puff Daddy yeah
um
but you think of Texas overall I love
Texas you can move here right I'll I'll
eventually be out here yeah me too I'll
get that no I don't know about Austin
I'd entertain it are you looking some
property but uh something there's some I
don't know what is some calling in Fort
Worth
what do you boys think of Fort Worth and
stuff you guys both from Texas no no
you're not
it's not really a
yeah but I just like it's not the it's
not the trendy like I don't like that it
when everyone's doing this like yeah I'm
gonna go over there like all our friends
move here and like it's the thing yeah
I'm like that that doesn't excite me I
miss my friends yes and that'd be great
but if that you know if if I move to
Dallas Fort Worth it's a what 20 minute
flight
yeah it's easy how far yeah the flight's
real short I'm taking it right tonight
wow super easy just to get here and do
sets and stuff [__] a or you can
drive get a cool car yeah I'll do that
there's no traffic here it's just in
Texas can I have a Tesla in Texas or is
that not cool
I think they're gay but yeah yeah but I
might want uh if I go with uh if I go
with a car how about the Toyota the new
Toyota 4Runner get out really Toyota
why get something cool man if you're in
Texas get some if you're looking for a
truck truck I don't know get a TRX get
it get too big too big get a raptor too
big too big I don't like the big [__]
boom I I just don't it's cost me 150
bucks every time I fill the gas block
off like give me something give me
something come on get a get a Hellcat
red eye
the Raptor one yeah those are six the
Bronco Raptor's sick the SVT Raptor
Bronco they're sick it was supposed to
be called the warthog then they pulled
the name which is is it a big truck what
is it no it's a Bronco you see the crash
test on Broncos don't get in a crash
with those things they fold up like a
[__] accordion that's fake news
I don't know that's cool that's a good
looking car that's the basic one that's
the basic model but you should have that
not crazy about Fords I'm driving one
right now a Ford yeah it's just it's you
get inside of it you ever been a Toyota
you [__] communist well but I feel
like they're better quality no if you
come to Texas and you're a Toyota dude I
mean they run they run forever so does
four Dudes there's more Fords on the
road than anything okay the F-150
Hellcat no dude I don't want that no
it's not a muscle car Dodge Challenger
red eye I don't want those things man
okay I want to I want a badass car that
that you know let's see look at the
Raptor there so the the Bronco you
wanted is like that hex squat machine
and that's a real deadlift bar yeah but
is that a is that a Bronco that's gonna
laugh forever how's the it's a Ford dude
they left for [__] ever really
I mean it lasted on the highway when OJ
was brought it from the cops it did last
oh my way when OJ was running from the
cops you're right down the 405 are they
able to hear you are you on a mic
we can get mics yeah we do have mics
back here whoa
whoa
Mike
catherwood just walked in he did just
looking a lot better it just got a lot
better looking in here so we're gonna
we're gonna so first of all this will be
our podcast yeah short short little we
did a short little uh this is an Austin
special we're calling this this is our
Austin special
uh the drinking Bros by the way speaking
of Texas I'm going to be in San Antonio
August 24 25 26. are you staying at
hotel Emma I sure am I'm at LOL I need
you to call your boy at hotelama
and uh I shouldn't even say I'm staying
at hotel llama because you know all the
fans yeah you're not very famous right
right you'll be fun and then um and then
I'm gonna be at uh in Salt Lake City at
Wise Guys September one and two two
great markets come get some I can't wait
and on this Friday I'm in Phoenix
Arizona stand up live two shows one
night Phoenix Arizona stand-up live I'll
be at JT wings during the day then
Saturday check them out be at the UFL
fights on Saturday with Jay chop chin
browse we're all gonna be there and then
I think it's August 17th and 18th I'm in
Oklahoma I'm sorry I'm in Omaha Nebraska
and Kansas City one night only and two
shows in each City there you go so get
yourself at thickboy.com yeah
um we'll see you in a little bit guys
all right kids love you